[Music]
what happens when you combine your
favorite superheroes with the world's
most adorable pups some of them are cute
some of them are downright scary but all
of them are simply irresistible if you
ever wondered what Deadpool would look
like in real life as a dog make sure to
stick around until the end of the video
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more videos like this and give us a
big thumbs up now join us as we take a
look at 15 superheroes in real life as
dogs super dog man it's a bird it's a
plane oh wait no that's a cute little
woofer dressed up as Superman and we
couldn't be more excited about it
someone Kali adores police and put this
whole situation under arrest whoever
decided to dress these pugs as Superman
obviously knows the secret to a happy
life and the secret to our hearts look
at that squishy face Superman and tell
me you wouldn't want him to save you
from Lex Luthor this dog truly has it
all with a face body and personality
that not even Lois Lane could resist and
we know what you're thinking where is
this pug Clark Kent
we're wondering the same thing if you
have a pug at home dress them up as
Clark Kent and post a link for the
picture in the comments in the meantime
we'll be staring at these pictures of
Superdog man the hefty Hulk knock knock
who's there the big old dog dressed is
one of our favorite superheroes The Hulk
with a puck this scary we can't believe
it was actually taken out in public
imagine if you were walking to the park
with your friends and out of nowhere you
got completely Hulk smashed by this
massive dog talk about totally
embarrassing and painful in our opinion
it seems like they should have at least
waited until this doggy turned back into
Bruce Banner
but then again what would they have done
with all that awesome green paint waste
not want not
oh and a quick side note for all you
fashionistas out there it looks like
this dog's owner had to sacrifice a
choice pair of jean shorts to complete
the outfit but it's just a small price
to pay to make your dreams come true if
you wanna watch just one more video the
premium is the platform where you should
go get early access to videos from the
things the taco the trendy the richest
and many other great channels in one
place with ad-free browsing click this
link to sign up for the premium and get
ready to binge watch videos from your
favorite channels
spider-man either my spidey senses are
tingling or I'm falling deeply in love
with this adorable version of spider-man
Mary Jane Watson better take care
because this web slinging superhero
needs daily walks and while this fluffy
guy usually moonlights as Peter Parker
he's obviously been bitten by a
radioactive dog spider and has gone full
arachnid that's good news for us
as he might be our only hope to save the
world from evils of Green Goblin and
venom
can you imagine this furry little canine
swing from building to building shooting
web and solving crimes we know that's
all we can think about but for now it
looks like this dog is just hanging out
in this unfurnished apartment waiting
for the crime and city to call on him in
the meantime maybe he could start
lifting weights since his muscles are
quite a bit smaller than his head keep
bulking Spidey
Captain America oh say can you see one
of the fiercest superheroes of them all
Captain America this patriotic
powerhouse is looking a little more
confused in his human counterpart but
hey who can blame him sometimes Captain
America or as he's known to his friends
Steve Rogers had been enhanced to peak
human perfection he's highly skilled and
armed and unarmed combat and he'd better
believe he's ready to defend a USA at
all costs that is after he's had his
food and maybe a good belly scratch he
also enjoys all the other dog pastimes
like licking peanut butter fetching and
adamant patriotism when he's not
catching frisbees or sticking his head
out the window
you can find him hanging out with the
rest of the Avengers they're a very cute
crew but we sure wouldn't want to be on
the wrong side of them Iron Man Tony
Stark had it all millions of dollars of
flourishing love life and a really cool
boat that is until he was kidnapped
received a chest injury and built
himself an incredibly powerful suit of
armor this suit allows him to fly way up
high in the sky produce powerful beams
of energy and gives him superhuman
strength as you can see this dog owner
has expertly adapted the Iron Man suit
to fit perfectly on his pup there's room
for all four legs and even a little
opening for his paws gotta have the
little paw opening although we're sure
this dog is super cute underneath we
have to say he's pretty intimidating in
the full costume we don't know what we
would do if we encountered this iron dog
on the street do you pet it run away
salute we're not totally sure but the
one thing we are sure of is that this is
one of the most intricate doggie
costumes I've ever seen
the only question is what happens when
nature calls well he's a superhero
so we're sure he's figured something out
Robin well Batman usually gets most of
the attention we'd be remiss not to give
a shout-out to the true bad boy of
Gotham Robin yes Robin is Batman's
faithful sidekick but any true fan knows
that when it comes to fighting the Joker
penguin or mr. freeze Robin is
irreplaceable that's why we were so
delighted to see that one fan dressed
their dog up as the man in the green
himself we mean just look at him
equipped with his signature yellow cape
and little black booties this costume
really nailed it and we don't know about
you but we could stare at that big old
neck and fluffy black face all the live
long day
not a bad apartment for a sidekick
either we're sure he spent some real
quality time in front of that marble
fireplace that is when he's not saving
the city from the worst doggy villains
Wonder Woman the first lady on our list
is the one and only Wonder Woman unlike
many other superheroes Wonder Woman just
actually first sculpted out of clay by
her mother Queen Hippolyta from there
she was given life by Aphrodite and went
on to be one of the most inspirational
and powerful superheroes featured in DC
Comics it's hard to imagine a more
adorable dog to play our leading lady
and this picture is just so perfect that
we need to take a closer look let's
start out with this little doggie space
the first thing you notice are those big
brown eyes tilted head and tongue
sticking out of a slight smile pretty
coy for one of the most powerful women
out there
this dog smiled combined with its
posture and outfit really won us over at
first sight in fact we think we might
just get this picture frames Batman he
goes by many names the Dark Knight the
Caped Crusader and even the big Mr Man
but no matter what you call him there's
only one Batman by now everyone knows
his true identity as the Jillian heir
Bruce Wayne but that doesn't keep this
man in black from keeping Gotham safe on
an average day you might find him
shredding through town in his Batmobile
walking the lake with Catwoman or
throwing batarangs at children's
balloons just kidding
Batman's one of the most altruistic
superheroes out there but let's get to
it this is one of the cutest superhero
dogs on the list look at him seriously
take a few seconds and look at this
little puppy he's so cute the only
disadvantage here is that his adorable
appearance does make him a little less
intimidating if we were a villain we
don't think we'd know whether to run
away or just give him a big old hug
actually we do know excuse us while we
give this little guy a hug Cyclops Oh
baby this is a dog bad to the bone
indeed if dogs could ride motorcycles
which they can it's this Superdog with
certainly be riding one let's not get
ahead of ourselves here what we're
looking at is Marvel character in x-men
superstar Cyclops along with the rest of
the x-men crew this peace-loving
character is part of subspecies of
humans known as mutants each mutant has
their own power and Cyclops is no
exception
with a simple motion he's able to emit
incredible power beam of energy from his
eyes in order to control the beams he
must wear special eyewear at all times
and that's exactly where our puff comes
in if we're being honest we think this
dog owner could have done a little more
work to dress the character but was such
an amazing piece of eyewear Cyclops is
hard to miss the Punisher someone hold
the phone because I'm scared
without a doubt Marvel superhero booth
Punisher might be one of the toughest
superheroes on our list driven by a
series of status surrounding his
immediate family our hero decided to
devote his life to battling the mobs of
New York City like all things in the Big
Apple
it takes some true grit to get by that's
no problem for the Punisher who's always
dressed in all black equipped with the
essential gear and roaming the city
fighting organized crime mirroring the
Punishers typical style this dog owner
has done a pretty amazing job of decking
out his pup as you can see he's got the
trademark logo and blazed on his chest
and somehow managed to find a tiny black
coat where do you even find the coat
that small and don't get us started on
those little red shoes somehow they
managed to make the toughest superheroes
look super cute labra Thor the story of
Thor has its roots in ancient mythology
in fact the character of Thor was
actually based on a Norse mythological
deity of the same name and he is the god
of thunder our super hero draws his
power from his trustworthy hammer which
he wields and always keeps at his side
though a hammer carrying god of thunder
might sound a little intimidating this
happy labrador is anything but his owner
did an incredible job replicating Thor's
outfit and we have to give them some
props this Labrador comes fully equipped
with Thor's hammer
conveniently hanging by his collar for
easy access whoever put this costume
together included our superheroes
trademark red cape wouldn't you just
love to see this hero dog running around
taking all the bad guys in your town we
know we would if this is Thor in real
life then sign us up the Green Lantern
one of DC Comics longest lasting heroes
is the incredible Green Lantern the
character is so old that it's been
around since the early 40s you know he's
got to be a pretty amazing superhero if
he's been around that long did you know
that the Green Lantern actually draws
all his power from a magical ring pretty
cool right although we can't see it in
the
picture we have to imagine that this dog
is wearing that magical ring somewhere
how else would he be able to get all
those magical powers what we can see is
the rest of the green lanterns
well-known costume this dog has been set
up with everything no Green Lantern
would be complete without his trademark
green suit and this dog's owner somehow
managed to find the one that fits
perfectly it even has the logo on the
back to top it all off he's also wearing
the classic green eye mask which hides
his real identity from villains and the
outside world the flash quicker than
light faster than rain we're talking
about the one and only speedy superhero
the flash up course the flash is a
classic DC character that harnessed the
power of speed to fight crime no only
that but he's part of the Justice League
along with Wonder Woman Superman and
Batman since his characters inception
there's actually been as many as 4
different versions of the flash that's
quite a lot but when you've been around
for over 70 years what else do you
expect that's right the flash is one of
DC's oldest characters right there
alongside Green Lantern and what better
dog to represent the fast-paced hero
than a greyhound greyhounds are known
around the world for their unmatched
speed and grace and boy does this dog
look fast whoever created this outfit
really took their time getting it just
right from the yellow ears the lightning
bolt on the back this costume is pretty
much perfect
Leonardo Cowabunga dude did you think we
were gonna forget about the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles
no way this turtle clan made a big
splash in the 80s and Donatello Leonardo
Michelangelo and Raphael quickly became
some of our all-time favorite
superheroes we watched some smash hole
pizzas and protect their sewers from the
shredder and his group of criminal
inches with all these fond memories in
mind we're beyond excited to discover
this canine version of Leonardo do you
know about all of the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles were named after famous
artists that's right and Leonardo was
named after the famous sculptor and
painter Leonardo da Vinci as a turtle
Leonardo is the most thoughtful of the
bunch which often brings into conflict
with Raphael who's a bit more haphazard
we think that this doggy does an
incredible job of embodying Leonardo and
he's definitely got the outfit to match
from the turtle shell to the signature
blue bandanna this little woofers got it
all Deadpool doggy now I know we've
mentioned a lot of superhero so far but
we couldn't leave you without talking
about one of the greatest anti heroes of
all time we're talking of course about
Marvel's famed Deadpool both loved and
hated around the globe Deadpool is known
for his sarcastic sense of humor and his
repeated break of the fourth wall
anywhere addition to the superhero world
Deadpool was introduced in the 90s and
even got
own movie in 2016 pretty rad whoever
decided to dress up their dog as
Deadpool did a truly incredible job and
the resemblance is so uncanny we can
barely believe our eyes you can tell
that a ton of work went into this
costume simply by looking at the shape
of the eyes spot-on beyond that the
color of the fur and the addition of
Deadpool swords makes this one a
complete home run with an amazing
costume and such a cute dog it does not
be your favorite is there a superhero
you'd like to see re-envisioned as a dog
let us know in the comments if you're
looking to watch another video right now
check on ten paw patrol dogs and real
life thanks for watching
[Music]